no attack thank you that you
are also simon reinink director of the
building today is next
and but what does the nexus institute
actually mean for you
I already saw that question coming I think
the nexus institute will
take you out of your regular group for a while and
actually forces you to think
about the big questions of life that
you often overlook in the issues of the day
and I think the publications are
also very helpful in this regard as it covers such a
wide range of  different thinkers
writers artists from all corners and
holes people who are asked to
contribute to the nothing is
square and I live it with great
pleasure and it also sets you
thinking again it often inspires me
in my work  once again looking
at the concert hall from another side
and also at my own life,
which was very beautifully said this afternoon, we
talked about images,
what does building mean specifically for you in
bisl, love me in
actually a continuous search
for answers to the  big questions of
life and I still think and I am by
nature quite a curious person and
I really like reading and if I only have the
time then I like to do it too and I
still think that in asking the
questions and
healthy  form of uncertainty questioning things
doubt that that
is a huge driving force in life to
discover new things and yet yes perhaps to
become a better person
to be able to become a better person
you now say that is a funny question because
how can racing help you  to help with this, there are
specific books that
have inspired you to be able to say that
we have the feeling that I
can become a better person,
my brain works so that I am looking for that, I am a
little short with my refrigerator,
jealous of people who do not have this,
that they  that shortage
it is not the case that I know exactly about the
title in theory that quote
I have that
concerns that quote I quoted that I do not just shake them
out of my sleeve but it is
true that when you read a book  him who
sometimes also reads a book or reads
a book and hears a piece of music
that it does something to you after reading
a book and you are a slightly
different person than before reading
the book and all that knowledge  that you
have while reading all those books that wave
somewhere on the set of processes in your
brain input with
which you do something again
and it makes you curious and a
richer person and
to name her two nice titles from
the nexus institute week of  the nobility of
the spirit a beautiful book by Van
Rob Riemen and a book that I perhaps
carry even closer to me is the book
that was published under the title the
university of life and what I
find so special about it is
that there are people at the end of
a life who
have experienced incredibly special things, such as those in the eighties and
the 90s, in some cases not all
money for it, but most of
those figures have experienced special things
and have lived through very
difficult times,
wars and  lack of natural disaster you ca
n't make it up and when
asked,
yes, they came up with a number of insights that
they have gained, not from their books
or they
are not asked to quote the large traffic jams,
we just say what have you
learned and a lot of those statements that
I still carry with me something like this:
stay curious,
be humble,
keep being open to new
developments,
very basic things that I think, God, how
beautiful that people who
have experienced so much life experience have experienced so
much life experience, have experienced so many
things that  basic wisdom
mega oh I love it
we also talked a lot
about music this afternoon about how music
can be inspiring how music and
education can inspire
as a director of the concert hall or
wherever I tell you what is specifically a
piece of music that is incredibly  It is
important that you are
inspiring again and again,
that is very difficult, I don't feel
like eating stew or kale every day, it
depends a bit on your state of mind
which piece of music inspires you and yes,
it is a bit of an advantage against the 80s,
but the music of  Baghdad volts and
stationery you can stay there endlessly
boot discovers new things here every time
and but also recently
we had the Jupiter Symphony last week, for example, the
last symphony
that Mozart wrote,
probably a piece of music of which I have
my idea how you can wonder how  It's amazing
that someone has invented something so beautiful,
to name just two whole ribs,
recent examples, but also
the mass in C minor by Mozart that
recently took place in the context of the
commemoration of French teams,
incredibly beautiful music and how
like thinking about the more titles I
going to mention it again so it's
not actually answering questions that is so beautiful
about the music and so much so beautiful